dieu sait que je n'ai pas le front
méchant je ne souhaite jamais la mort de
jean mais si l'on ne mourrait plus qu'un
vrai tu fais sûrement talus je suis un
propres fossoyeurs les vivants quoi je
n'ai pas de remords a gagné mon vin ce
dos des plans mais ça me tracassait
d'ailleurs les antennes à contrecoeur
suis un fossoyeur et plus flash la bride
à mon émoi et plus les copains s'amuse
de moi ils me disent mon vieux par
moment là une figure l'entraînement je
suis un pauvre fossoyeur j'ai beau dire
que rien n'est éternel peut pas trouver
ça naturel
et jamais je ne parviens à pendre la
mort comme elle vient
je suis un pauvre fossoyeur n'ai vu ni
connu
mort à dieu si du fonds la terre on voit
bon vieux il lui le mal que m'a coûté la
dernière pelt et je suis un pauvre
fossoyeur